I mean I I do think that it should be
decriminalized I don't I don't think
that that's a I think picking your own
mushrooms but I also think that the
cannabis model which is kind of like you
know that we see in California might not
be right here just because I I mean my
own experience and interviewing dozens
of people who had been through
psychedelic therapy is that these drugs
are uniquely powerful and that the role
of the guide is very important to a to a
successful experience it's not to say
people haven't had terrific experiences
you know taking mushrooms or LSD and you
know going to I just talked to someone
who went to a festival last weekend and
had a fantastic experience you know
that's all true but there is another
kind of experience people have to and
you know given a poor set and setting
and said as you're in you know your
internal environment and your external
environment setting people have you know
experiences that really Rock them
psychologically and and leave people in
a really bad place and so how do you
mitigate that risk and I do think that
the the idea of a guide a train guide is
a very important way you know the the
big lesson part of the issue with
psychedelics in our society is they kind
of burst upon our culture in the 50s and
60s without any preparation suddenly
these incredibly powerful interesting
molecules show up psilocybin is
discovered in Mexico by the first
Westerner Gordon Wasson in 1955 he
writes a big article in Life magazine
and suddenly people want it and descend
on this town in Mexico and then LSD is
invent is discovered or really tried out
in the 40s and and becomes this drug of
research and but we got the molecule
without the package we got the molecule
without the traditions the rituals the
ceremonial rites of passage the right
yeah the rites of passage so if you look
back the history of psychedelics which
is so much older than the
than the 50s and 60s in America in
Europe you see that that many cultures
use these drugs these medicines in a
very carefully-designed context you
never see people using them alone and
this is whether we're talking about
ancient Greece Siberia
you know the Amazon Central America they
never used the drugs alone it was always
with elders or shamans or curanderos
presiding and there was always ceremony
in ritual and there's a reason for that
yeah it's not just superstition it's the
fact that there was enormous respect for
the power of these these medicines and
that they shouldn't be used carelessly
hey you know it was a capital crime in
Greece the Greeks had of what we think
is a psychedelic ceremony once a year
the Elysian mysteries and there was a
potion they took that appears to have
been a psychedelic it allowed people to
travel to the underworld and meet the
dead and and enter other realms you
could only use this medicine in that
ceremony and it was it was a capital
crime you could be you could be executed
for using it recreationally and and I
used that word advisedly but so there
was a reason for all that and and the
kind of individualistic use that you
know we've pioneered in the West you
know may not be the best yeah so I think
we have to be open to that and and be
willing to learn from history